and we go back to South Florida for a
big game coming up on Saturday night
let's go to Ali laforce well Jalen was
this the well-rounded full effort that
you've been looking for and if so how
did you find it absolutely it started on
defense we uh set the intensity and we
came out we played good basketball
tonight and uh it looked fun out there
we know it's a make or Miss League how
did the main threes rejuvenate and
excite your defense as well because I
know you said it starts with d but it
all goes around doesn't it yeah we just
got to be consistent tonight we're with
a tougher playing team we set this on
from start to finish and uh we had a
great team win we hit shots and they let
us get to so don't let us get another
one okay that's what I was going to ask
you next now that you found your way is
there any stopping you
only thing that can stop us is us we
just got to come out and play our game
have fun and let God do the rest we'll
see in Miami thank you all right thank
you they have the second best record in
the NBA one win less than number one
overall seed Milwaukee and the Boston
Celtics the most balanced team this
season number one network rating in the
league they'll come back from a
three-nothing deficit to make it a 3-2
series